من الناحيه الطبيه كيف ستزرع ومن مدى
سهوله زراعتها في دماغ البشر
جواب السؤال هذا ابغى بس اشرح
المشروع اللي عند الى ماسك هذا يعني نموذج
من جمجمه الانسان
هذا الجهاز راح يكون حجمه 2 سم
شغل الاولى
يكون ازاله من
يعني جزء قطعه بسيطه من جمجمه الانسان هذا
هذا العمليه راح يسويها جراح مخ
والدرجه الثانيه دخول
الخيوط اللي راح تكون لاصقه مع الجيب هذا
على حجمها هذا باستخدام روبوت معين
الروبوت هذا من شركه
على استخدام الشبت هذا
للناس اللي مصابين عندهم نصف عندهم شل
النصفي او شلل الرباعي يبغى له
هنا
يعني في المخ وبعدين
في حبل الشوكي بيكون بين بين التواصل بين
النوريك هنا وهنا
الناس العادين لو انا ابغى احرك اصابع
لازم الاشاره تجي من المخ تروح الى رقبتي
حبل الشوكي الى الاعصاب بعدين اقدر احرك
اصابعي بس الناس اللي عندهم حاله شلل ضربه
في رقبتك يكون بين مواصله بين النيران هنا
وهنا والرقبه عشان الشخص هذه يحرك بيننا
انا صراحه معجب الان مصر فهو من اذكى ناس
اللي عرفه في جيلنا هذا
واتوقع ان ان رح ينجح في انجازات انا مع
اني ابغى اثر الايجابيات
من الناحيه الثانيه
هكذا شرائح يمكن ان تعيد الحركه للمصابين
بالشلل ويمكن ان تعيد الابصار للمصابين
بفقدان الرؤيه الطبيه
طبيا قام
في احتمال بس الاشياء الي ما حد يذكر عنها
ان هذه عمليه عمليه
بامكاني يغير الشريحه
للسهوله مثل ما يقول انه ما حد يبغى ايفون
كل واحد يبغى ايفون 14 لان 14 اسرع واقوى
وكذا
واحد يقدر يطلعه ويستخدم على
اه لان مضاعفات مثل حاله صرعه سكته دماغيه
نزيه
وبعد يعني كل واحد يبغى يركز على ايجابيات
المشروع هذا
السواء على حيوانات وما ندري عدد
الحيوانات اللي ماتوا يعني
واشياء هذه وبعدين ادعي انه يقدر في
الحجاره على الانسان على مستوى امريكا
خلاص سته شهور
دكتور يعني تجارب عن الحيوانات اظهرت همم
ظهور نزيف داخلي اصابات بالصرع وحتى
التهابات انتم دكاتره الى المدرسه سهل
عليكم انه تزرعوا هذه الشريحه في دماغ
الانسان من دون حدوث
صعب جدا
ما ما اعتقد ان هذا سهل الدرجه ان يدعي ان
بس يحط الشريحه هذا داخل الانسان المخ
وفجاه يعني يرجع ال ال الوظائف يعني
الواحد يقدر يحرك ايدينا بعد ما يكون
عندها حاله شلل فهذا صعب جدا مو بسهوله
يعني نحنا انا يعني مخ الانسان مو سياره
مو بالماكينه معينه هذه قاعدين نتكلم عن
خلايا الجسم همم ما اعتقد انها همم راح
يقدر يعني يبدا في التجارب في على الانسان
خلال سته اشهر هل في المستقبل يمكن بس
حاليا مع المعلومات اللي عندنا من الشركه
هذا